this is also happening in an election
year so the president's running for
re-election and then you have former
Vice President Joe Biden who's sort of
just hanging in the wings they're trying
to figure out how to make his mark I
don't know if his campaign or that
candidate are particularly well-suited
for this moment where you're isolated in
your house and you're trying to do you
know communication through in your
living room it doesn't feel like it's
gonna work well yeah well it hasn't thus
far he put a studio in his rec room he
made a speech the first one that
teleprompter gave out on him he's not
very reassuring when he says things like
come on man it's not very reassuring
he's got an adversarial relationship
with a teleprompter and the streaming
age is just not kind to him and he's
tried to play in an arena that I don't
think you ought to be playing and he's
trying to sort of say I'm the critic of
President Trump and let's reel back to
2008 Barack Obama was the presumptive
nominee of the Democratic Party
admittedly it was the fallen after the
convention this is before the convention
but Biden is the presumptive nominee
Obama was the nominee but Obama's went
in and was the leader of the Democratic
Party he was sitting there with Pelosi
and Harry Reid saying here's what we're
going to do in response to the financial
crisis in this instance Joe Biden has
never been a leader of the Democratic
Party but he is the leader now and
instead of acting like the leader he
sort of let Nancy Pelosi be the primary
figure in the negotiations on what was
going to go into the relief bill and
Chuck Schumer to be her side man and he
was just basically buying into
everything that they did when she threw
out that eighteen hundred page bill with
35 million for the Kennedy Center and a
hundred million for public radio and you
know same-day registration and you know
about ballot harvesting now made legal I
mean he was senescence buying into all
of that stuff and and and and and yet
been saying stop let's get this yeah
baby said we're not doing this no more
Kennedy Center and money in this bill
this is a crisis he would have looked
like a leader but instead it looked like
he was following Pelosi